hey guys Ryan right in the house here
and Alyssa be crazy next to him that's
right so today we're gonna check out a
game trailer that just dropped
Assassin's Creed syndicate debut trailer
no uh-uh alyssa is a fan of the
Assassin's Creed franchise
yeah I've barely played it but you guys
kept asking for it so I thought who
better than someone actually [ __ ]
plays the game right I will said you
liked the trailers - oh Allah trailers
are epic and the cool thing is when you
play the game the games are just as
amazing as the trailer makes it out to
be to be rated mature mmm yes like you
are
London
it's a bloody marvelous time to be alive
an age and invention so many clever
blokes dreaming up impossible machines
sorting away more gold than Queen
Victoria herself
but none of those shillings ever makes
it into the pockets the poor devils
whose blood is spilled building this
glorious empire the working class he
walks through life unaware of the
machine that drives them let's wake them
up then shall we
Oh
yeah that's Queen City good ah oh my God
look so good it looks really good well
have you ever played any of the
Assassin's Creed I played a little bit
of each one I've never actually like
played the entire game but I will tell
you man I like the character a lot most
of the time the characters are like so
serious and brooding but this guy you
could tell has a little bit of a sense
of humor yeah yeah I like seeing that he
seems like he'd be a fun guy to play as
because I like the heroes and games I
like crack jokes every now and again you
know he seems so actually is really good
about doing that too is they're very
consistent with their content and how
they arrange the humor within each game
because you know with each cut see they
have a lot of cutscenes and they're all
beautiful so well done they do make it
very entertaining it's something that I
really love about the entire franchise
as a whole and it's something that
honestly it does keep me coming back
because the gameplays awesome so are the
cutscenes it's a very well rounded very
fun series I will agree with that you
know it's just it's not anything against
the game I just it's been a year since
I've actually taken time to be like I'm
gonna finish this whole game I'm gonna
have to borrow Brotherhood I should play
the whole thing and you're gonna be on
me no my point I saw that they have
Amazon they have like one of those like
for assassin Creed's collectors the
first one so I wanna I want to actually
play it from the beginning because
there's so many and I love getting
involved in the world of it because it's
you know fictitious history and I love
how they do it you know it's it's really
neat how you can be a part of history
but in this cool fictional world but did
you know this is something that they've
always done is every person that you
kill is a real person in history oh
really yeah isn't that awesome that's
pretty cool yeah so I mean even though
there's story within the game may not be
exactly what it is in reality there's
still real people you can look them up
look up their names and there they are
somewhere in history yeah and I will say
it like I've seen a lot of cinematic
shows for Assassin's Creed but as a
trail
alone that was the most badass one yeah
probably is majorly contributed to the
music - I've never seen them do that
with the music that's you just some type
of cinematic it epic music where they
just do a full-on you know cutscene
that's usually something that they do
but I've never seen this kind of trailer
and it was perfect
I'm from Burbank I would find it very
very cool if they use that kind of music
in the actual game not just the trailer
but I think they would do that I mean
they're they keep very very true to the
era that the game takes place in I'm
just saying it would be cool this up it
won't be cool but it wouldn't make sense
if a nice tail made sense it did I love
a nice tail yeah it was about it it was
perfect I know I'm gonna get a lot of
crap for saying it's perfect anyway guys
a rating time I will definitely be
playing Assassin's Creed syndicate and I
will definitely be buying it anyway guys
thanks for tuning in if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real Rejects crazy sauce over here has a
channel elissa be crazy a lot of fun
games on there and you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram or Twitter but we're
hoping to get product placement we're
getting a lot of followers yeah so we
want product placement like hair ties
hair ties are great they tie up your
hair obviously they can make for
wristbands and you can also make funny
looking images with your pubic hair
that's why I grew up my pubic hair
because I like to turn my pubic hair and
sit kind of like a Japanese samurai
little hair what I do with my pubes just
remember it's all fun and games until
someone gets hurt that's when it gets
interesting
all right guys um this shout-out is
gonna be a little long uh he this guy
name is Chris Ryan hey guys will love a
shout out in exchange for a story from
my past childhood okay here we go he has
a reaction and review channel very
unique right so ELISA is gonna act out
the story for us while I read it alright
here it goes so this story takes place
when I was about I don't know thirteen
fourteen now is this really socially
awkward kid growing up so I didn't have
too many friends this one guy hung
around with Harry was like my best
friend probably because he was about as
hot as me we like to walk through the
alleys on the way home we both came from
a rough part of town so people were
extinct ibly wary of us and stayed away
one day we're walking home when we find
this puppy we assumed it was a stray but
saw it had a collar he was named love I
found it funny to call him Gaylord
instead we were 13 and dumb what can I
say
so we decided to take care of Gaylord
until his owner showed up we took him
with us to the shop to get him some food
and then headed back to that alley where
we found him
we were then met by this huge heavyset
black guy and I couldn't help but notice
the pistol tucked under his belt I
remember being so terrified and looking
at Harry the guy walks up to us and is
all like what the [ __ ] are you doing
with my dog but then something came over
me and out of nowhere I told the guy to
[ __ ] off and then get in a Gaylord is
ours now I still remember that sinking
feeling I don't think I'll ever forget
it the guy just had this look on his
face employed it's gonna shoot me but
then and I'll never forget this
Harry pushed me out of the way and got
hit instead oh it's getting dramatic the
guy took a bullet for me the black guy
took off running but I stayed with Harry
I looked down at him and I remember the
tears of my eyes as I watched my best
friend die oh my god you're look baby
joke I'm so sorry dude oh my best friend
died saving me
why did you play along with me telling
you to act it out Alyssa you shouldn't
have done that
bad on you bad on you but then with this
last bit of strength this [ __ ] looks
me Randy eyes and yells shot through the
heart in your
blame you give love a bad name is it a
joke oh this is a joke
you got a really twisted sense of humor
or your your I think really depressed
out of all the things that I've gone
through on this channel I think this is
the most awkward I've ever felt I I
don't know how to feel
it sounds very realistic blue but then I
puffy dainty a Lauren or centum is
pretty a crazy story
I don't know shout-out to mr. Chris Ryan